[Musik]
seit dem jahr 2002 gibt es einen
liebling des publikums der faz und
dieser liebling heißt volker reiche für
alle diejenigen die sich jetzt gleich
fragen werden naja den namen habe ich
vielleicht doch nicht so richtig präsent
den sei einfach nur gesagt volker reiche
ist der mann der strizz erfunden hat
tritt das ist eine figur eines
büroangestellten heutzutage ist ja sogar
mittlerweile zum chef des unternehmens
in dem er arbeitet avanciert juniorchef
danke für den hinweis völlig wichtig und
völlig richtig und stritt ist eine serie
die sm hat acht jahre lang in der faz
fast jeden tag gelaufen ist dann
ausgesetzt hat aber immer wieder mal in
größeren abständen zurückgekehrt ist und
als bald wird sie noch einmal ganz
regelmäßig wiederkehren in unserem
magazin die woche das jeden freitag
erscheint nun sagt ja jedes bild mehr
als all die worte die wir darum machen
können könntest du für unsere zuschauer
einfach mal ein bisschen zeichnen damit
man auch mal schaut wie das bei dir ab
läuft ja mache ich doch gern das ist der
herr stritt die titelgebende figuren
dann habe ich zb hier den herrn paul
auch sehr beliebt bei den stritt
freunden das ist ein etwas höherer
charakter weniger romantisch als den
herrn strizz text über mit den augen an
nicht immer hier bei ihm würde ich mit
der gesichts linie anfangen bei
ebenfalls mit den augen an
das ist besser hat man den mehr unter
kontrolle als wenn man nicht vor
zeichnet dann haben wir zum beispiel
auch hier den tassilo dass du so ein
verträumter hund auf dessen hunde
hinterhof die aktion der tiere
stattfindet
also es gibt ein großes panoptikum von
figuren und ich denke obwohl der platz
in der woche eine halbe seite in der
zeitschrift die woche ja deutlich
kleiner ist denke ich doch dass ich in
diesem format auch erzählen kann
reduzierter aber schon in dieser form
dass die figuren so zu sagen
verschiedene meinungen haben diskutieren
und nicht nicht wie bei einer karikatur
sagen kann das ist der punkt und schluss
[Musik]